okay so we have this problem the among
the human condition is problematic yes
we live in an age we live in an age of
incredible abundance incredible
opportunity but also increasingly high
levels of despair the burden and the
gift of consciousness is a double-edged
sword
right it gives us this immense capacity
to create and to express ourselves and
to do everything we've done look how far
we've come look how fast we've gotten
here at the same time it makes us
uniquely aware that we are finite and we
are limited and I believe that the
crisis of our age is a crisis of meaning
and I think that that is the that is the
source of the high rates of despair and
anxiety and depression and the high
levels of medication and we need an
antidote to the human Kanaan dream I
would say and that's that looking for
that antidote is what fuels my videos
that's why I do what I do my videos are
like sort of these verbal explorations
of me trying to work through you know my
own you know sort of my preoccupation
with making sense of things and finding
a way forward so that's that's where
that's the inspiration behind my work
existential bummer I guess is the
genesis of everything else everything
else is in response to the existential
bummer and this is an amazing way to
unleash that creative potential through
so you okay so we say this is a crisis
of meaning it's a problem and you're
providing an antidote through shots of
awe what other antidotes do we have how
else can we explain this problem to make
it more relatable to people about how to
find the answer so well one of the ways
that I think we can the the the the the
diseases of depression and anxiety are
both characterized by excessive
rumination right our inability to get
out of our heads again the burden of
self-consciousness is that we're
thinkers but when thinking can also
become oppressive because in the face of
death we can be paralysed to act you
know like to be fully naked and
trembling before the
Kosmos is a scary thing and so it could
send us into these loops of despair this
excessive rumination and
self-consciousness which characterizes
anxiety and depression anxiety is too
much possibility and I'm terrified I'm
being torn apart you know by fear and
depression is the cave the walls are
caving in and I'm stuck in this small
reality and I can't transcend it and so
on and so forth but both of them are
characterized by excessive rumination
and self-consciousness and so one of the
ways out is to get out of our heads and
this is where for me I discovered the
power of flow States so for those of you
or not we're not familiar with flow
there's a book written by a guy called
chick send me hi called beyond boredom
and anxiety and most of us oscillate for
the most part between these two states
of mind boredom and/or anxiety and
beyond these two though is the state of
consciousness that many of us are
familiar with even though it tends to be
fleeting and finite but it's a state of
consciousness that is typically fills us
with incredible joy and Rhapsody and
this is a state of flow also known as
the runner's high also known as you know
being in the pockets if you're a jazz
musician being in the zone if you're an
athlete and Steven Kotler and Jamie Weil
who are the founders of the flow Genome
Project they describe flow as a state of
consciousness in which you feel your
best and you perform your best right so
think about that right it's a state of
mind in which you feel your very best so
your blissed-out but also your levels of
performance and whatever the task at
hand is the triggered flow go through
the roof so if you're a writer that's
like when you completely lose yourself
and you know five hours feels like two
minutes and you wrote the best thing
you've ever written in your life and you
feel amazing and you're energized and
you're pumped and it's like haha give me
some more of that you know if you are a
musician it's it's when you go on some
improvisational solo and you just hear
like you you had an out-of-body
experience and you were like in the
audience watching yourself and you
couldn't believe if you were doing you
know I certainly feel hello sometimes
when I do my videos and that it just
totally feels like I mean the wordix
tasses means to be beside yourself to be
outside yourself you know so it really
does feel like you
your own way it reminds me of the movie
Black Swan you guys seen that movie
Black Swan it's a wonderful line where
the choreographer is telling her you
know the only thing standing in your way
is you
yeah you know that's a metaphor right
but it's a metaphor saying the only
thing standing in your way is the dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex which is the
inner critic the inner Woody Allen
that's constantly self-doubting
everything and saying oh it's all for
nothing because we're all gonna grow old
and die one day oh it's all for nothing
you'll never make it oh it's all for
nothing because you're not good enough
you quiet that and then something else
emerges and more curious you and we're
opening you a more present you right and
people experience that as relief they
experience that as liberation and it
turns out that when you're in these
states pattern recognition goes up
lateral thinking goes up risk-taking
goes up so you find yourself doing
things in spite of yourself and that's
where all the good [ __ ] happens right
everything great because of the edge of
our comfort zone everything you want is
on the other side of fear I mean these
bumper stickers are there for a reason
and so you know I came across I mean I
had my own experiences of tapping into
flow it started probably in high school
where I consider myself very much an
introvert and I'm kind of in certain
situations that can be very shy other
situations that could be quite outgoing
but um I stumbled upon certain triggers
that would put me into this zone and my
thing has always been making videos I
used to make like short films with my
with my brother when we were kids and
always making videos I was obsessed with
videos my whole life and and what I
found was that when I entered what I
came to know eventually as a flow state
it felt to me basically as a I would
describe it it's just a poetic reverie
where I just like loosened up you know
and so it's like loosening the cognitive
loosening the mind loosening basically
shut down the part of the brain that was
like second-guessing it was like nah I
don't dance at parties no way stiff
holdin back part was pushed aside and
something else emerged and it doesn't
matter what triggers flow I mean
sometimes flow can be triggered from the
adrenaline of being on stage sometimes
flow can be triggered from the
excitement of something that just beckon
you know sometimes flow can be triggered
from breathing exercises jazz musicians
and freestyle rappers love using
cannabis
you know Allegra California whatever
floats your boat truly but as long as it
gets you there and and what I you know I
didn't know that it was called flow at
the time but what I did realize is that
there was something ecstatic about
feeling in that state of mind because it
provided such a relief from the
incessant chatter that clearly I have to
deal with and so my you know there was
there was a feeling of grace and
gratitude when I found relief from my
rumination and my existential despair
and so then I decided that that has to
be what I build my life around and
eventually through you know research and
a lot of reading I came to learn all
about flow and the neurobiology of flow
and advances that are happening in the
psychology technology and neurobiology
and pharmacology of ecstatic flow States
there's an acronym to describe flow
called stir selflessness timelessness
effortlessness and richness so when
you're in flow your sense of self
vanishes that's the inner critic your
sense of time how time is regulated in
the brain gets shut down so time dilates
and the terror of the passing moment is
no longer there at least you're not
aware of it and final is finally
richness information richness you have
access to more data because all the
cul-de-sacs and error messages of the
rumination are pushed aside so that's
all you have to remember stir self
listen this time listen this
effortlessness and richness and that's
flow and of course whether it's a surfer
an athlete a musician people who build
their lives around their flow report the
highest levels of life satisfaction so
there's something to that right so it's
like we start with the human condition
and the existential bummer and then we
figure out okay how can we address this
problem because you know we're here and
we might as well
something with our lives and so for me
it very quickly became okay these
experiences of flow flow and the art
that came from the flow yep because on
the other side you know whether flow is
for me every time I have flow it's
almost like a mystical experience it's
an experience of the divine of the
transcendent it's I call it the
aesthetic orgasm and and then and then
all the content that comes through is
usually in response to experience of
such rapture that it demands a response
you know so if people are looking to be
more creative in their life I would say
the question is not how to be more
creative the question is how to find so
much ecstasy in whatever it is that make
gives you flow and then in the afterglow
when you come down from that experience
you're gonna be so you have so much
creative output to share with the world
that you won't know what to do with it
you know so there's a relationship
between mood regulation and creativity
and so I say you know flow has to do
with mood regulation has to do with like
tapping into that ecstasy of the present
moment and then and then seeing what
happens when you come out of that lots
of creativity for me
so definitely flow I would say has been
for me one of the one of the antidotes
to the human can under me yes